j'ai toujours eu pour ambition
d'améliorer le monde pas de devenir
millionnaire ou célèbres juste
d'améliorer les conditions de vie de
l'être humain sur notre planète il y a
dix ans pour répondre à cette ambition
j'ai décidé de créer avec des amis une
société de services informatiques ayant
pour objectif de faire passer l'humain
avant l'argent dans l'entreprise
aujourd'hui dix ans plus tard une
centaine de salariés s'y épanouissent et
ont prouvé que c'était possible
cette aventure a été une grande source
d'épanouissement pour moi à tel point
que j'en étais à expliquer à tout le
monde comment être heureux tellement ça
me semble être une évidence mais ça
c'était avant
avant de prendre conscience de l'ampleur
des enjeux climatiques
et la l'épanouissement a laissé place à
autre chose j'ai créé une société où il
fait bon vivre mais s'il ne fait plus
bon vivre sur notre planète ça
m'interpelle voyez
alors à ce moment là j'ai eu un petit
coup de mou
une petite prise de conscience quoi ok
pour être honnête un bon gros coup de
déprime à ce moment là j'ai compris
pourquoi les scientifiques nous
recommande de ne pas dépasser une
augmentation des températures de 2
degrés 2° ça correspond à la courbe en
verte des émissions de gaz à effet de
serre que nous émettons aujourd'hui
je crois que pour moi à l'époque deux
degrés
c'était juste un sweat en main
et puis j'ai pris conscience que c'était
beaucoup plus insidieux que ça
l'augmentation des catastrophes
naturelles des sécheresses des canicules
j'ai beau être frileux franchement je
préfère garder mon sweat éviter les
catastrophes naturelles
et puis ça ne s'arrête pas là au delà de
deux degrés d'augmentation il se passe
des phénomènes en cascade dont on n'est
pas vraiment en mesure de prédire
exactement la gravité à titre d'exemple
il y a le pergélisol ou aussi appelé
permafrost en anglais le pergélisol est
un sol gelé qui renferme beaucoup de gaz
à effet de serre avec le réchauffement
climatique ce sol dégel libère alors ces
gaz à effet de serre qui vont accélérer
le principe du réchauffement climatique
qui lui-même va encore plus à accélérer
le dégel
enfin bref c'est ce qu'on appelle un
emballement
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
s'emballe elle aussi comme vous pouvez
le voir on est plutôt sur une courbe une
trajectoire à 3 ou 4 degrés donc
manifestement on n'est pas sur la bonne
courbe il y aurait comme qui dirait une
erreur d'aiguillage et ce coup là on ne
fera pas croire que c'est la faute de la
sncf
et ici on n'est pas juste en train de
parler d'un problème d'aiguillage qui a
fait quelques victimes d'après l'un des
derniers rapports du giec le groupement
d'experts intergouvernemental sur
l'évolution du climat
on parle de 3,3 milliards d'êtres
humains d'ores et déjà présents d'ores
et déjà sur cette planète qui sont très
vulnérables au réchauffement climatique
et aux impacts du réchauffement
climatique
et moi pendant ce temps là je faisais
passer l'humain avant l'argent dans
l'entreprise
j'ai donc
cherché à voir comment je pourrais avoir
un impact sur tout ça
j'ai commencé à m'intéresser à
l'altruisme efficace le principe c'est
de d'analyser les conséquences de nos
actions pour pouvoir cibler les actions
qui ont le plus d'impact ensuite je me
suis intéressé aux 6,81 miller l'idée
ici c'est de dire qu'on passe la plus
grande partie de notre temps au travail
et donc 80 miller dans notre vie et donc
si on veut avoir un impact sur notre
monde c'est certainement en utilisant ce
temps à bon escient
alors ça peut-être surpris d'apprendre
que à l'époque une des premières
recommandations du site c'était de
gagner beaucoup d'argent pour pouvoir
investir cet argent dans des
organisations qui oeuvrent pour votre
cause
ni une ni deux j'appelle un ami et je
lui dis ça y est j'ai trouvé ce que je
vais faire je vais aller faire traders
aux us gagner beaucoup d'argent et
réinvestir ça dans le climat
et là il m'a dit pourquoi pas mais je te
vois vraiment pas faire ce job là et à
ce moment là j'ai pris conscience que
moi non plus je vous conseille vraiment
d'utiliser votre joker l'appel à un ami
enfin tout quoi pour moi ça a vraiment
bien marché
j'ai donc opté pour une autre stratégie
présente sur le site également puisque
ce qui m'anime c'est de mener des
actions concr est de transmettre des
connaissances pour permettre des prises
de conscience je vais aller transmettre
un maximum de gens des informations sur
le réchauffement climatique et sur les
solutions qui sont associés
et c'est à ce moment là que j'ai eu la
chance de découvrir time for the planet
et que j'ai pu retrouver du sens en
impliquant à titre bénévole dans cette
organisation
alors qu'est ce que c'est que time for
the planet c'est une entreprise à
mission oui premier truc surprenant
c'est pas une association mais bien une
entreprise a mission à but non lucratif
et la mission c'est de lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique
jusque là ça commençait plutôt bien pour
moi
mais j'avais quelques doutes je me
demandais si tout ça ce n'était pas
juste de la com ça me paraissait trop
beau pour être vrai alors j'ai commencé
à m'impliquer progressivement dans le
projet et j'ai découvert un projet très
terre à terre très concret on va en fait
financer des innovations qui vont
permettre de capter ou de réduire les
émissions de gaz à effet de serre des
biens et des services que nous utilisons
alors évidemment avant de faire ça il ya
d'abord la sobriété l'idéal c'est de
réduire nos consommations en amont de
manière à pouvoir ensuite réduire avec
des innovations d'aller encore plus loin
dans la réduction de nos gaz à effet de
serre
et quand je parle d'innovation je ne
suis pas en train de parler d'innovation
high tech je suis pas dans du techno
solution nice mais l'idée ce n'est pas
de créer des jetpacks photovoltaïque ou
des trucs comme ça hein pas du tout on
est en train de parler d'innovation
concrètes et terre à terre pour lutter
contre les gaz à effet de serre à titre
d'exemple voici les trois premières
innovations qui ont été financés
un climatiseur qui utilisent de l'eau à
la place des gaz habituellement utilisé
dans les climatisations il faut savoir
que ces gaz représentent à eux seuls 2 %
de nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre
une voile de kite surf qui s'adapte sur
n'importe quel bateau de navires
marchands d qui permet de réduire les
émissions liées au carburant de 20% ça
représente des sommes colossales à
l'échelle mondiale
et l'olivine un minéral naturel qui est
utilisé en guise de sable sur des normes
étendues de plages et qui permet de
capter du co2 là aussi dans des
quantités très impressionnante il existe
des places de ce type dans le monde à
l'état naturel par exemple à l'île de la
réunion
mais time for the planet ne s'arrête pas
là pour aller encore plus loin
avoir encore plus d'impact et donner
encore plus de sens on va rajouter
des éléments que j'aimerais vraiment
retrouver dans d'autres organisations et
d'autres entreprises
le premier point c'est une collaboration
à l'échelle mondiale les innovations
vont être partagés en licence libre
c'est un petit peu comme de l'open
source ça permet à n'importe qui de
pouvoir réutiliser ces innovations
partout dans le monde sous certaines
conditions
ce concept donne de l'espoir dans la
capacité de l'être humain à
passer de la compétition à la
coopération
un autre élément c'est que le projet et
non lucratif concrètement vous ne pouvez
pas gagner de l'argent en investissant
sur ce projet oui parce qu'ici on n'est
pas avec une association où on va donner
de l'argent comme je les dis mais dans
une entreprise admission dans lequel
vous allez investir et en fait cet
investissement c'est un petit peu comme
si vous faisiez un prêt à taux zéro pour
la planète et ce qui est fou c'est que
malgré cette absence de lucrativité il y
à déjà plus de cinquante quatre mille
citoyens entreprises et organisations
qui ont investi qui ont financé 10
millions d'euros sur ce projet en
l'espace de seulement deux ans et demi
ça me rassure de voir qu'il ya autant de
gens qui sont prêts à s'investir sur un
projet sans intérêt financier
j'en viens au point qui m'a
définitivement convaincu
je peux agir à l'échelle mondiale sur le
climat
je peux en appliquant sur ce projet
contribuer à la réduction des gaz à
effet de serre que nous émettons dans le
monde
et je peux le faire de deux manières je
peux investir de l'argent pour financer
plus d'innovation je peux investir du
temps pour évaluer les innovations qui
sont soumises et permettre ainsi d'avoir
la meilleure sélection des innovations
et je peux aussi m'impliquer de plein
d'autres manières différentes par
exemple personnellement j'ai fait le
choix de donner de mon temps pour animer
des conférences dans les écoles
d'ingénieurs et dans les entreprises
pour permettre de transmettre au plus
grand nombre des informations par
rapport aux enjeux climatiques et aux
solutions comme time for the planet
et j'ai décidé de faire ça gratuitement
pour permettre à un maximum de gens
d'être sensibilisés à ces informations
est de pouvoir à leur tour s'investir
soit avec de l'argent soit avec du temps
et pour terminer ce projet a permis de
révolutionner les standards et les
normes dans lequel elle évolue
time for the planet est à l'initiative
du dividende climat en partenariat avec
l'ademe l'agencé de la transition
écologique
cet outil le dividende climat permet de
faire la distinction en un
investissement qui va financer de la
captation et de la réduction carbone
d'un investissement qui ne le fait pas
et cette distinction il va pouvoir se
faire par les sociétés qui capte qui
réduisent du carbone puisqu'elles vont
émettre des dividendes climat auprès des
investisseurs
alors ce dividende climat c'est pas
comme un dividende financier ça ne
rapporte pas d'argent c'est purement un
indicateur qui permet de savoir combien
de tonnes de gaz à effet de serre j'ai
permis de capter avec mon investissement
et ça c'est très utile c'est évident le
climat pour les entreprises qui vont
pouvoir valoriser en annexe de leur
bilan carbone ce fameux dividendes
climat c'est un puissant c'est un
puissant levier pour inciter les
entreprises à financer de la captation
ou de la réduction et permettre
d'atteindre ainsi de contribuer à
l'atteinte de la neutralité carbone à
l'échelle mondiale
tout ça pour vous dire que les
entreprises à missions
peuvent faire évoluer les normes et les
standards dans de leur domaine mais
également elles peuvent améliorer le
monde comme nous l'avons vu juste avant
et si nos entrepreneurs se demander à la
création d'une entreprise qu'est ce que
je peux apporter à notre monde et à
notre société et à notre planète et si
nos entreprises se mettaient à avoir des
missions d'intérêt collectif
généralement nos entreprises
s'intéressent peu ou pas assez en jeu
collectif qui peuvent nous apporter du
sens comme l'environnement le social
humanitaire etc pourtant en s'attaquant
à ces sujets elle pourrait améliorer
leur attractivité en termes de
recrutement augmenter leur nombre
salariée engagée dans l'entreprise et
améliorer leur image de marque sans même
avoir besoin de faire du greenwashing
et pour les entrepreneurs et les
dirigeants qui souhaitent laisser une
trace sur notre planète c'est
certainement plus via ce genre
d'initiative avec des initiatives à
mission collective que par un
enrichissement personnel
être une entreprise a mission c'est
aussi quelque chose d'important pour les
travailleurs qui ne viennent plus pour
un salaire mais qui peuvent aussi
contribuer à une cause commune qui va
changer l'avenir de notre monde
je suis convaincu également que ces
entreprises la mission peuvent être un
des éléments clés à l'amélioration des
conditions de vie de l'être humain sur
notre planète voire même de sa survie
pour ma part je me sens à ma place
aujourd'hui en contribuant à ces enjeux
climatiques je fais quelque chose qui
m'anime et qui me donne du sens et qui
me semble être bénéfique pour l'humanité
et vous
quelles actions ou projets bénéfiques
pouvez-vous réalisé pour notre planète
et notre société